hey y'all it's a movie retrospective and
guess what we're talking about today
buffy the vampire slayer yeah the
original movie not the tv series the
original movie and i kind of feel like
the tv series was so
you know amazing and so popular that i
feel like there's probably a not
insignificant subset of the population
that doesn't even know that there was an
original buffy the vampire slayer movie
yeah it's kind of overshadowed the movie
i remembered the movie but then forgot
about it and in my mind it was just a tv
show from then on out and yeah and i saw
a couple of episodes of the tv show back
in the 90s when it was on and i liked it
i thought it was a good show and it's
sarah jessica parker
sarah sarah michelle sarah michelle
geller sarah jessica parker
that's another totally different woman
michelle gellar was in it
and uh she was a cutie she was kind of
like a kind of like a britney spears
kind back in those days where she looked
and she drove the show and had a lot of
good characters on it but this
movie was kind of forgotten i think
by a lot of the people that probably
just knew it from the tv series this is
a great movie it's a good movie we've
watched it it is actually really fun now
honestly it's just kind of like okay so
i did see a few episodes of the buffy
the vampire slayer show which i think
ran for what eight or nine seasons it
was not like and then it had an offshoot
show called angel yeah it wasn't sabrina
the witch or that something no that was
like that was that was different but um
yeah and then well there was like a lot
of kind of supernatural knockoff
well wasn't that based on i thought
sabrina the teenage witch wasn't that
based on like some archie [ __ ] like
wasn't that an offshoot of like one of
the archie comics
back in the old days i thought it was i
please forgive me if i'm wrong but i
thought i don't know how i know that or
why i know that piece of information but
it just popped into my head so it
sounded right so i said it yeah um
coming out of that television series
though how much of vampire stuff
happened like [ __ ] angel
yeah that was a direct offshoot though
because that was one of the characters
yeah that was from buffy and uh girls
liked that one these were more i think
really kind of more marketed towards and
charmed was a big one that didn't have
anything to do with buffy that was
witches but
but that was also very popular around
the same time yeah and they were all
kind of i think marketed towards teenage
girls really a lot of them but guys
watched them too they're good
i would think the ultimate during this
period though was one the [ __ ] james
cameron had that was called oh
oh [ __ ] what was the name of that one
had jessica alba in it
oh um yeah it was good yeah i think i
know what you're talking about oh she
was a genetically engineered yeah we've
talked about it before but i can't
remember like what it is i'll remember
it eventually i can't remember what it
was called but i kind of feel well the
thing about the archangel oh yeah yeah
yeah i think it was called dark yeah i
remember you telling me about that i
don't think i ever saw i went and tried
to get that on on dvd and they went like
a hundred bucks for it
well it's kind of it's a
i mean buffy the vampire slayer the tv
series and some of the other
supernatural [ __ ] that came out at the
same time like charmed and stuff are
actually still pretty beloved yeah so
those are gonna be a lot easier to get
but
the thing about the original movie of
buffy the vampire slayer which came out
in 1992
was that
it's funny because it's funny thinking
about it now because you know of all the
stuff that's happened subsequently
but
the concept of kind of like a vapid
valley girl fighting vampires was very
very weird to an early 90s audience i
mean even kristy swanson who played
buffy in the first one like i saw some
clips of an interview with her from the
time where she was talking about you
know when she was first pitched to the
movie and she was like buffy the what
like that was like the dumbest thing
ever
um they called it though yeah i mean
like i said it and the thing about it i
think too that there's kind of a
misconception that it like really tanked
at the box office it didn't it wasn't
like a huge success or anything
but it made more than twice its money
back like it was it was a pretty i think
it was only 7 million like to make it
and i think it made 16 17 million and
this is on the backs of one a really
weird premise for the time and two
obviously back in 1992
that you know there was no tv show no
that was a completely original character
yeah so people were just going to see it
on the strength of the premise
and
it still like made its money back but
because you know the show came along
later like i think it was four or five
years later that they did the show um
everyone just kind of like forgot that
the movie even existed i feel like um
it was a good idea though yeah it's a
great idea it's a it was a mishmash
and they they mashed together two things
that were opposites
you know [ __ ]
preppy
little valley girls and vampires that
didn't happen
but you could make a good movie based on
that yeah and they did
i mean i don't think the movie is as
good as the show was obviously
but
it's detailed it's still well it's still
like really entertaining now i will say
that um obviously because joss whedon
was the guy behind the buffy the vampire
slayer show uh this he wrote this movie
uh buffy is his original creation which
a lot of people know so he had actually
written the screenplay for this movie
when he was like pretty much i don't
think he was like really all that
well-known uh at this time period he was
very young
and the screenplay got picked up by
actually uh dolly parton had a movie
production company called sand dollar i
think
and her production company picked it up
okay so um and then there was also uh
this thing called uh kazooie i think
it's called kazooie like productions
who's like a japanese woman fran kazooie
who was the one who ultimately ended up
directing this movie and she was the one
that kind of her production company they
they did stuff like um you know
introduced like south park to japan and
stuff like that so uh so that's who was
kind of behind the making of this but
like i said joss whedon a very young
screenwriter
now he has been uh noted to say that
that he didn't really like how the movie
came out
the original conception of the movie
um was much
darker and like it still had funny stuff
in it but uh when the movie was kind of
like going through the production
process a lot of the darker elements
were taken out
and more funny stuff was put in and
while he liked christy swanson's
portrayal of buffy the character he's
like she's not exactly the way i had
written her originally or the way i was
picturing her sarah michelle gellar was
closer to what he had been envisioning
like from the beginning but that said
this is still i mean it's mostly a
comedy let's put that out there it's not
it doesn't really have a lot of horror
movie elements to it it has vampires in
it and they kill people and stuff but
it's it doesn't even have as much horror
element as like the lost boys it's
pretty much a comedy it's still it's
still a good movie it is though i really
i actually really have a lot of
affection for this movie i think the
tone was kind of it wasn't what the what
you know the writer wanted
but the tone worked in a big movie
and the setting worked
basically what they did is it's about
it's taking place in where in california
i think it says los angeles but i
thought it was pasadena plus yeah it's
going to be i thought it was pasadena
because at one point she goes out to
like where they keep all the parade
floats which maybe it says pasadena on
it okay and i assumed that it was
pasadena because that's kind of what the
name of the parade is yeah but it could
very well be so it's out in california
in the suburbs
and this
cheerleaders
senior year of high school yeah and uh
a bunch of stuff happens relationship
stuff happens vampires happen uh she
gets mentored by like a obi-wan kenobi
type guy who's a vampire hunter who's
he's ancient from the past well i don't
think he's um i think in the show
he was ancient
in the movie i think he keeps like
reincarnating
right so he's not like the same person
every time necessarily he's not same guy
he's because i think he says at one
point donald sutherland plays him by the
way uh merrick i think he says at one
point i'm born with the knowledge that
so i guess it's like a reincarnation
type deal but it but really if you stand
back and analyze the movie it's very the
story and the setting and the tone is
very much like the musical grease
it's like the grease but it's not a
musical
and it's got vampires in it which you
say that's [ __ ] crazy no it works it
kind of has a
certain nostalgic feeling to it and it
was it felt like it was supposed to be
nostalgic even for the 90s
even though when you look at the movie
it's a real time capsule it kind of
reminds you of the way people were in
the 90s why things looked it's so 90s it
hurts yeah
but it's good though yeah it's it's and
i don't mean that as a bad thing yeah
it's super super 90s there's mall
culture in it you just see how much
things have changed since the 90s i
couldn't even understand really what the
girls were saying in the very beginning
i had to put the subs on because it's
been a long time since i've heard people
talk like that
um which is just
a teenage slang that went in and out of
style real quickly
um
it's just a good the styles and
everything you forget how hyper feminine
a lot of the styles were back then with
the hair and everything it looked good
it was just from another time and
there's giant earrings
earrings which i could i kind of dug
some of those actually
um
how super feminine girls were
especially cheerleaders cheerleaders
[ __ ] bent over backwards to be super
super family
uh but [ __ ] [ __ ] fighty catty oh
yeah they show that in here big time
because like buffy her circle of friends
yeah they're all these kind of just like
they they're you know they're stupid and
proud of it there's like who cares about
history i remember going yeah
and it's like you know they're all like
just cattly like picking on everyone
else's clothes and they weren't stupid
per se just that their priorities were
all about what brand names you were
wearing yeah maybe yeah maybe not stupid
shallow
relationships and just insulted people
and stuff that's the way they work
but it's but it does kind of poke fun at
at the way that was but not not over the
top it was just kind of it's the movie's
actually very accurate you know
yeah and actually in the late 80s i grew
up in florida yeah and um you know i was
in high school this came at 92 i
graduated from high school in 1990 but i
remember
some girls being like this yeah like
even in real real late 80s yeah real
real clicky and what happens is it is
like the head cheerleader girl
runs into a couple of what you would
call like burnouts they were like heavy
metal type guys
listen to punk rock or goth or stoners
they look like stoner
they're kind of like in between
and then
they reject those guys uh they reject
them but then later on one of them gets
turned into a vampire and the other one
tries to flee town and he falls in with
buffy and then a romance kicks off which
is kind of like there's an element of
like forbidden love because i was like
valley girl from the early 70s yes you
remember the valley girls no oh the
movie valley girl yeah it was like that
from 1982
yeah and so she was she was and he's
he's actually out of high school he's
been i think he'd been out for about a
year yeah because he's he's has a job he
was just like a mechanic yeah yeah
he'd been out for a year or two
and uh he has a motorcycle and [ __ ] so
but it's just a good kind of like
grease or rebel without a cause uh just
a lot
it's kind of reminiscent of a lot of
classic movies that take place in this
point of a person's life
when it's the end of high school
there's a lot of them were like this but
they were good kind of little uh you can
tell that it was influenced by heathers
as well which had come out a couple
years prior
um heather's is like a much darker
comedy
um but i mean this one is just basically
pretty much a straight up comedy it does
have some dark elements but not a lot
where you laugh off the dark elements
yeah well whereas heather's was just
like all dark but they were making it
funny which was why it was like
controversial at the time but you still
had and i think even
um
at one point in buffy the vampire slayer
somebody uses some slang that was also
used in heathers which i don't think was
in common parlance prior to heather's
because you know the writers of
heather's kind of made up their own
uh slang so it wouldn't date yeah um you
know so saying stuff like what's your
damage and stuff like that i don't i
don't remember anybody saying that
before that movie came out but after it
came out everybody said it a lot of
slang was local made it but
made up by a click itself for that
particular high school that happened a
lot too
but um
by the end of the movie it's happening
on prom night pretty much yeah it was
prom night with it it was prominent it
wasn't actually it wasn't the actual
prom it was just the senior dance
because remember there was like a gag
about that's right this is the last
dance of the year oh except for the
spring formal oh and the semi-formal i
know this isn't that oh and the senior
prom so this wasn't scene it was like a
prom like festival it was a prom like
products yeah
but i remember that it wasn't quite prom
but yeah the the
by the time that's going down of course
a lot of the kids have been turned into
vampires and of course that means
they're goths now they're showing up in
looking early 90s
got [ __ ] pvc [ __ ] bondage outfits
and [ __ ]
but they look good you know the costumes
all look good the clothes the fashion i
mean very 90s
and uh now now would be considered
[ __ ] quaint retro but kind of good i
forgot how colorful [ __ ] was the big
patterns
you didn't see that all the time in
person but you always saw it on
television because a lot of what they're
wearing in this
in in this one would have been pretty
expensive
uh if you went to your average
some place in middle america a lot of
them will still look like something out
of the 80s for [ __ ] big poodle
haircuts and [ __ ] [ __ ]
terrible [ __ ]
terrible [ __ ] jeans mom jeans and
[ __ ]
but the thing about it though is that
these kids are these kids are in high
fashion because they're well yeah these
these girls are you know their parents
are upper middle class yeah they don't
care where they are either well yeah
they kind of like uh
they kind of could which they changed a
little bit for the show uh but yeah in
this one it's kind of like i don't i
don't know if i'd call it like a running
gag but it is kind of a thing where
these girls are just like out doing
whatever and like their parents are just
by we're off to hawaii or bio rafting
and they don't really give a [ __ ] what
they do they're not mean they just don't
really give a [ __ ] what they do now
there's some good vampire action [ __ ]
when the dudes when when the burnouts
when the when the one guy's friend gets
flipped into a vampire he shows up
floating outside the window it's kind of
like something out of the salem's life i
like seeing i was like oh salem's lot
moment
and they had him they had him hooked up
pretty good he had [ __ ] and pointed ears
and uh looked like uh looked like
nosferatu from [ __ ] kind of looked
like nosferatu that was david arquette
by the way who would later go on to much
fame and scream and many other movies
yeah
the the thing that the only thing i
could say kind of lacked about the movie
is that um
rutger howard played the head vampire
lothos yeah lothos he wasn't
intimidating at all uh not to me i
didn't like this mustache i thought it
looked look bad um he wasn't a very
interesting or deep character neither
was
the guy the burnout who got turned into
a vampire because he looked cool he i
thought that maybe they'd give him some
nosferatu type scenes
where he could be spooky and [ __ ] and
funny at the same time it didn't really
happen they didn't
they didn't go into the the problems
that happens to you when you become a
vampire it was just superficial i'm
about to learn now i'm a god
it's mostly i mean it's mostly because
it was mostly about
buffy yeah and about her being like i
said this vapid cheerleader who is kind
of forced to
you know rise to the occasion it's like
you're you know merit comes tells her
you're the chosen one yeah there's one
every generation and you have to fight
vampires and then like him training her
to do that and her kind of like becoming
a more mature person and like taking on
that responsibility my only complaint
was is that those two vampires were not
quite deep enough characters that there
should have been
they should have done a little bit more
with them
should have been like you know
there should have been a scene where you
kind of
where they kind of transformed slowly or
something they had to fight it always
like those kind of scenes in vampire
movies
or they're like uh they're kind of or
they try to flip their friend that kind
of thing he didn't he was just gonna i'm
gonna let me in i'm hungry he's gonna
you know he was just gonna kill us
you're floating
that made me laugh really hard yeah i
forgot about that i think there should
have been a little more depth with at
least some of the vampire characters
that's my only complaint well i think
that that's maybe one of the things that
joss whedon wanted to do initially and
that's why he went off and did that more
with like the series yeah like i said
this one
it's this is actually a really good
movie i saw this movie a bunch of times
like back in the you know mid 90s um so
much so that and i haven't seen it for a
long time so we were watching again last
night
there were so many lines in there that i
remember using with my friends and stuff
and i had forgotten that that was what
movie it came from so it was like really
kind of like i was like oh my god we
used to say it all the time and i forgot
that that's where that move that came
from but um you know it's like i said
they they kind of went in a more comedic
direction with it and that's okay yeah
the you know the vampires aren't really
all that well established i love that
like the um the kind of second in
command vampire is played by paul rubins
aka pee wee herman
uh his death scene and this is hilarious
like when she stakes him and he's like
oh
oh yeah oh and then he falls down and he
gets back up like he's doing it again
yeah that's why we heard
uh but yeah this this might have been
like the only you know what's funny i i
found this out today that part was
actually supposed to go to joan chen
who
that's crazy because she normally is in
kind of like you know oscar-worthy type
movies uh but then she couldn't do it
for whatever reason so they got paul
reubens of all people but yeah so one of
the one of the burnouts like the main
burnout character uh pike is actually
played by luke perry now one of the
things that might have
kind of affected the making of this
movie
i had thought when we were watching this
last night i was like oh yeah luke perry
is in this who died in 2019 i'd totally
forgotten about that he was only 52. he
died of a stroke
i had totally forgotten until i was like
until i was looking it up today and i
was like oh [ __ ] that's right he did die
didn't he but yeah that's [ __ ] up so
luke perry when we were watching the
movie last night i thought oh this is
pre 90210 luke perry i was wrong
90210 started in 1990 two years before
this okay so luke perry was already a
[ __ ] massive star at this point um
and he wanted to be in the movie but he
said well you have to accommodate my
90210 shooting schedule
so for this movie i think they shot it
in five weeks which is
not a lot of time
um so it could be that some of the stuff
was maybe like rushed a little bit
through like they didn't have time to do
multiple takes or they didn't you know
it could be that because they had to
like hurry hurry it up because they
wanted him to be in it because he was
such a big name another thing that we
noticed we're watching it and all of a
sudden in the middle of a dab basketball
kid game one of the kids pops out and
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] been asked ben
affleck he's like a 20 year old ben
affleck standing there yeah because i
was like i had forgot there's a [ __ ] ton
of cameos in this yeah uh yeah ben
affleck shows up as another guy on like
the he didn't have any lines i don't
know he's just
shows up on like one of the basketball
teams uh ricky lake shows up as
the waitress in like that at that
restaurant
yeah that was ricky lake um seth green
shows up in this uh like i said david
arquette but that's not a cameo because
he's actually like a full character
hillary swank is actually a full
character in this too she's very very
young this was you know before oscars
and before she got like super famous i
heard somewhere too i think it was from
uh minty's minty comedic arts channel
that
originally this movie was supposed to
have a cameo or cameos by david bowie
and mick jagger they were going to be
vampires like old rock star vampires
but i guess they couldn't get them or
you know it fell through or for whatever
reason but yeah but they were supposed
to be in it or that's what i heard
anyway
but yeah so so it's just funny how many
i think there were even more
cameos than that but i can't remember
like who they were but i specifically
remember seeing ben affleck because you
can totally tell that it's ben affleck
when they have his face he's only in
there for like 10 seconds two seconds
yeah he like backs off like one of them
one of the one of the vampires is like
playing basketball or whatever um but
yeah so
it's just crazy too how [ __ ] but yeah
it's like all the [ __ ] lines in this
that
i that we used to use that i had
forgotten about like when the first time
that donald sutherland as merrick
appears and they're at all the girls at
the mall and they go in this elevator
and the elevator door opens and he's
standing there and one of the girls goes
what a homeless yeah and i was just like
oh my god we used to say that sometimes
too like when somebody looked like a
look like a bomb and another one too
like when uh when all the girls are like
in the restaurant and then the two
burnouts luke perry and david arquette
are like over by the bar
and he's like you guys are the ones from
the movies we hate you guys and i was
like oh my god we used to say that too
like in that same inflection and i was
like i had forgotten that it was from
this movie the mall scenes are a trip
because yeah i'm in i'm into like
watching ball videos [ __ ] like the
little mall videos yeah we love those
dead malls from like yeah [ __ ] in any
way danbot
aces adventures and you're the belle and
all that yeah you look at you look at
the scenes and that was like the height
to mall culture
yeah [ __ ] jam-packed all that
high-fashion [ __ ] expensive stuff in the
windows you look at those places now and
they're empty they're dead
dead
because amazon and just markets changed
i think it depends on where the location
is part of is they built too many of
them
and that was just how you used to
distribute products
and it's just funny just to to remember
how big those were and how how busy
those were you go there there need be no
choices still they couldn't you had to
[ __ ] buy what they were offering
couldn't get goth clothes there
you had to [ __ ] mail order all that
[ __ ] you know what's kind of funny about
you saying that they built too many
malls which was uh a problem in a lot of
areas which is why a lot of them closed
they eat they kind of made like uh a
little bit of a joke about that in this
movie in 1992. well because remember the
girls are all in the mall and they're
like let's go to a movie or something
and then they're like well what about
this theater and they're like oh they
don't even have thx or dolby or anything
yeah what about this other mall and
they're like oh that's you know they
have oh they show like uh what'd she say
they show previews for foreign movies
yeah so they had like all so they named
like five or six other malls that they
could presumably get to like in a short
period of time they were mall theaters
that they were talking about yeah and
they and they turned their nose up at
amc because the because the ushers all
had zits that's right
yeah but she didn't say she didn't say
that she said acne something yeah acne
central or something yeah i think it was
acne central it's like oh the they're
all acne central because they all had
that like kind of
valley girl sort of everything had to be
yeah so it's like they had this so they
did actually kind of make a joke that
there were that many
movie theaters or that many malls like
within a very short because i i noticed
that like it's kind of like the market
could support it though
yeah i mean back then it could i
remember even kind of small towns having
like
a lot of malls like within
yeah a little bit but yeah that was how
you botch it
it's yeah and it's not so much i mean
there's there's
a lot of the scenes in this are kind of
in the mall not like a lot of them but
there are a few there's some more you
know the girls are shopping and there's
some when they're in a movie theater and
then there's one later where christy
swanson as buffy is out like buying a
dress for the dance and stuff like that
but it's not it's just kind of cool to
like see them all it's not like super
centered around for you youngsters that
did not grow up in the mall era the mall
made sense it was futuristic they came
out of the 50s
they were thinking about them in the in
the late 40s
it was to replace downtown
downtown areas you didn't have to go
downtown you could park and you could
have your downtown in this one area and
it was covered and it would be
air-conditioned
which was like mind-blowing back in
those days
air conditioning hell yeah
didn't matter if it was raining
snowing or hot you could you could be
downtown inside indoors there's an
indoor downtown
well yeah that was that's all it was
yeah
but it's you know the culture has
changed so much that they're not really
online sales now that they don't really
support it anymore yeah but yeah another
thing i wanted to say too that even
though okay so joss whedon's original
conception like a couple of the things
that i found that he wanted for the
original character like i said in in
terms of it being darker
was that
merrick who does die in this um but in
the movie he's actually stabbed by
lothos like lothos stabs him in the
heart and he dies in the screenplay he's
actually supposed to he got turned into
a vampire and he kills himself to keep
from
turning himself into a vampire so there
was that and also at the end of the
movie
buffy was supposed to
burn down the entire uh high school gym
like we're in a carry type not carry is
like psychokinetic but uh she was
supposed to burn down the whole thing to
destroy all the vampires uh that doesn't
happen in the movie although i i do
really like the scene at the end where
most of the high school kids like
survived a couple of them got turned
into vampires some of them got staked
and there's a scene where there's like
they're in the gym where the dance was
and there's like dead bodies laying
around and like the administrators have
their detention detention like on the
dead bodies which i thought was like
very funny wasn't that guy in office
space you said yeah he was yeah he was
the guy i can't remember that actor's
name dude they kept taking his desk away
and they forced him to work downstairs
and they wouldn't that's right that's
right even stop paying him it's
that looks like the same guy it might be
the same guy i forgot to look it up but
that i i actually laughed out loud when
he was putting detention slips on all
the dead bodies detention detention
detention detention that's like i don't
know that made me laugh but like some of
this i think christy swanson was
actually
she was really good in this i kind of
feel like she hadn't been she was in
some stuff she was in flowers in the
attic i remember her in that uh she was
in uh deadly friend remember that she
was like a
robot cyborg type thing do you remember
that movie no
you don't remember the scene where she
throws a basketball at somebody and it
like smashes their head and it explodes
and stuff you should see that it's it's
actually pretty fun it's i'm sure it's
terrible but i i remember that scene
fondly i remember her being in that but
so i i don't know i really like her in
this she's like really charming like in
the beginning she's you know very
shallow and vapid and everything like
you know she's at the
graveyard like waiting for these
vampires to come out she doesn't believe
it yet and then she's like looking at
america like looking her nails going got
any gum you know what i mean it's like
that type of situation you know she's
like what i know and it's like that
maybe that made me laugh really like she
couldn't believe it you know she's like
okay whatever like who the [ __ ] doesn't
have gum it's just it made me laugh
because i i knew a girl one of my
friends in high school and she was
always like that she was always like
where's my gum who's got gum i need some
gum goddamn it and she was always like
[ __ ] yeah um and then there was the
whole thing with the hairspray too like
her spray in the fire and lothos's face
with the aqua net
so i thought that was pretty funny too
because i was like oh yeah i remember
back in the late 80s and early 90s with
everybody having hairspray in their
[ __ ] locker
big [ __ ] bangs sticking up and
everything like that just hilarious but
yeah so if you've only seen the tv show
and are only just now finding out that
this movie exists
then i mean don't go into the movie
expecting it to be like the tv show it's
similar uh the concept is similar but
joss whedon changed a lot of stuff when
he you know he changed the series to be
more like he originally conceived it so
it's a lot darker
the character is a little bit different
um and it's less i mean it still had
funny [ __ ] in it but it was like less
comedic i feel like i do you know i've
only seen like you know a handful of
episodes so like not really an expert on
it this one is much more like a straight
up comedy um but that said it's like
you know and some of the jokes don't
exactly land but i don't know there's
just something really like charming
about it maybe it's just because i saw
it a bunch in the 90s so i have kind of
like a nostalgic
sort of warmth and affection toward it
but i don't know i always just really no
it's just the tone of the movie yeah i
just i just really had always had a lot
of fun with this movie and i just
thought it was like really cute and like
really entertaining yeah it's just a fun
movie that's that's yeah it's just
totally fun and like i said it's just
hilarious to think now that
a concept like this was a little bit
weird in 1992 like a valley girl
fighting vampires like now everybody be
like seeing it you know what i mean but
or something like that but i don't know
i kind of feel like conceptually it
would have been kind of strange for the
time uh so maybe it's a little bit ahead
of its time maybe not too much ahead
because it you know like i said it
didn't tank it didn't make money but
after the series came out obviously uh
it kind of got overshadowed to the point
where i think some people don't even
know that there was a movie that came
out in 1992. now we watched this on 2b
for free
but i think by the time this video goes
up because i noticed like before we
watched it uh a little thing next to the
title said expires in two days yeah so
they might be taking it off it hasn't
been on there that long so you if you
want to watch it you might have to pay
unless they put it on another streaming
service wouldn't be much darn right now
yeah i probably not um because like i
said this is a little bit of a forgotten
film and that's kind of sad because
there's actually some really funny [ __ ]
in this and there's a lot of really big
names in it
and a lot of actors that
were cameos or that had small parts that
actually went on to be super super
famous later on so it's like kind of fun
to like spot all the
people that were in it before they got
really famous so yeah i mean
definitely go check it out um it's
really fun it's really worth watching
like i said it's kind of like valley
girl or grease but with vampires in it
um but yeah check it out and tell us
what you think about it in the comments
and that will do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye